[Music]
[Music]
so what is one of the most worthwhile
investments I've ever made of energy
time whatever it might be I would have
to say creating my own real-world MBA
and for that some context way back in
the day I was pining after going to to
Stanford Stanford GSB Graduate School of
Business because I really wanted to go
there undergraduate I ended up not going
and then I thought wait but I can get
back to the pine trees and the beautiful
terracotta buildings for a Business
School and it also be a nice two-year
vacation that looks good on a resume I
went through the process of applying
twice I went through everything and it
always ended at the tour of classes
because I would find one or two classes
I loved there was one I think it was
called inside venture capital with Peter
Wendel which was fantastic but then
there were all of these theoretically
heavy abstract conceptual classes that
were really uninspiring to me and I just
felt demoralized didn't know what to do
so what I decided at the time because I
was also having lunches with someone
named Mike maples Mike maples jr. who's
a spectacular investor and he would ask
me for PR or a launch marketing advice
related to his startups and I would ask
him then about deal structure why he
chose one startup instead of another and
ultimately I decided to wait a minute
why don't I take what I would have spent
on Business School which is $120,000 at
the time like $60,000 a year so 120 K
two years and just create the Tim
Ferriss fund in quotation marks which
would be my real-world MBA and I would
ask Mike if I could invest alongside him
just small amounts of money the
assumption this is the most important
part being that I would lose the hundred
and twenty K it's a sunk cost right in
the same way that tuition it's gone
once you pay it's gone and you hope that
at business school or in my real-world
MBA the skills I would develop all the
things I would learn the people I would
meet the network that I would build
would be worth more than
120k overtime and right out of the gate
I made a stupid decision and lost the
first 50k what a dummy on the first
investment oh so I was just like oh okay
now what never Mike's saying that seems
a little aggressive and I was like no
man this is gonna be the next difficult
boom like shook my head and yeah
complete like Walking Dead immediately
and I continued then to refine things
and ultimately that led to early-stage
investments in Facebook Twitter Boober
Alibaba you go down the list the 50-plus
companies over the next ten years
following that because that I ended up
enjoying it and it worked out by far the
biggest financial winds of my life
probably forever quite frankly have come
from the initial experiment of doing a
real-world MBA where I expected to lose
all the money I put in 120 K over 2
years and that's blows my mind so that
was the best investment I've ever made
and you can mimic it in other smaller
ways whether you want to or dream of
being a novelist a dream of being an
ABCD or e you can create that type of
real-world education hey guys if you're
enjoying the tips and tactics and how-to
on this channel or in the podcast the
Tim Ferriss show I made this for you
try the mentors a short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list 130 of
the best at what they do people who are
icons legends and ask them all the same
questions these are people in some cases
I wanted to reach out to my whole life
ranges from many many billionaires
cofounders of every company imaginable
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to powerlifting everything else
country stars actors directors and you
can spot the pattern so some of my
friends have said this is the easiest to
read most useful book that I've put
together yet so check it out tribe of
mentors dot-com you can find sample
chapters the whole list of mentors
everything tribe mentors calm